pour boeing les 737 max sont prêts à
reprendre le ciel les défauts du
logiciel de vol fautif le mks ont été
corrigés les modifications sont en cours
d'évaluation par la ffaaa mais des
experts québécois soulèvent des
questions fondamentales liées à la
structure de l'avion des questions
jamais discuté publiquement à ce jour
j'ai le primo et ingénieurs il se
spécialise dans l'identification des
risques et la prévention des accidents
sylvain allard est un ingénieur
spécialisé en développement et
certification de systèmes critiques et
commandes de vol leur spécialité
le système qui contrôle cette aile à la
queue de l'avion
le stabilisateur horizontal précisément
le système que comment le logiciel
mks stabilisateur horizontal est une
surface absolument critique aussi le
vérin qui contrôlent ce mouvement-là se
brise aussi la logique qui comment on se
verrait lui fait défaut on parle avions
un petit mouvement de set elle a une
grande incidence sur celui de l'avion or
en analysant les données des boîtes
noires des écrasements gilles primeau et
sylvain alary ont observé dans les deux
vols des glissements anormaux du
stabilisateur
si on regarde y'a pas de commande du hem
casse il n'y a pas de commandes des
pilotes
par contre la ligne rouge ici démontre
qu'un mouvement du verre un contrôle du
stabilisateur horizontal donc le vérin
bouche quand on a pas de commande
ce sont des mouvements très facilement
observables et qui selon nous selon
règlement 395 or ne devrait pas avoir
lieu selon ce règlement de lagence de
l'aviation américaine se verra ne doit
pas bouger même à la vitesse de plongée
de l'avion ce qui inquiète ses experts
c'est que ce système critique ne semble
pas avoir été mise à jour depuis les
débuts du 737 en 1967
sun nous mène à nous poser la question
que lorsqu'ils ont fait des changements
sur le max est ce qu'ils ont pris en
compte l'effet de ces changements-là sur
le dimensionnement de cette veyron
en d'autres mots est-ce qu'on a dépassé
les capacités de severina avec les
changements du max la question mérite
d'être posée
j'ai le primo et sylvain alary réclament
des réponses à leurs questions et un
examen plus approfondi des 737 max avant
leur retour il sibyllin duval radio
canada montréal